Hey look guys my name is a chana welcome
back to my stable flood theories over
the last couple of episodes we took a
look at what the static keyword meant in
certain contexts and today we're going
to have a look at one other contact that
you might find the static keyword in and
that is in a local scope so you can
actually use that akin a local scope to
declare a variable and that has a bit of
a different meaning than the altitude
static that we looked at and the idea
behind this meaning makes a lot more
sense if you think about the two kind of
considerations about to make one way
declaring a variable and that is the
lifetime of the variable and the scope
of the variable the lifetime refers to
how long that variable will actually
stick around for in other words how long
it will remain in our memory before it
gets deleted and then the scope refers
to where we can actually access that
variable so of course if we declare a
variable is that a function for example
we can't just access it in another
function because the variable we
declared is going to be local to the
function we declared it in so a static
local variable allows us to declare a
variable that has a lifetime of
essentially our entire program however
its scope is limited to be inside that
function and it really has nothing to do
with functions in particular I mean you
can declare this in any scope really I'm
just using function as an example it's
not really just limited to being inside
a function could be in front if
statement to be anywhere which is why
again there's not much of a difference
between static in a function scope
versus static in a class scope because
the life time is actually going to be
the same the only difference is that the
one in the class scope anything in the
class can access it anything that has
anything that is inside that class scope
can access that static variable however
of course if you declare one inside a
function scope it's going to be local to
that function of living local to that
class let's jump in and take a look at
some examples so the simplest example is
going to be just to create a function
and then declare some kind of static
variable inside it so I'll just make
that again I equals zero what this means
is that when I call functions to the
third time this variable will be
initialized to zero and then on
subsequent order functions it's not
actually going to create a brand new
variable really easy way to check this
out is if I just print the value of I
and then I increment it every time I
call the function so if we didn't have
static here what you would expect is
that
time you call this function I get set to
zero then I get incremented to one and
then we print one - pecan well and in
fact we can test that out by just
calling function a whole bunch of times
here we'll call it five times we'll hit
up five to run our program and you can
see that we get one printing five times
because as I just explained we create a
variable every single time and we set it
equal to zero we then increment it to
one and then we print that to the
console now if we wish make this static
then it's very very similar to if we had
just moved this original declaration out
here so if we run this code and it
doesn't really matter if this has static
or not and our case is going to be the
same if you want to know more about what
static doesn't that sense you can check
out the video that's linked somewhere so
if I run this code you expect I to be 0
incremented 5 times and so you'll get 1
2 3 4 5 which is exactly what you get
however the problem with this approach
is that I can access I any where I could
set I equal to 10 over here in between
function calls and suddenly this
dramatically changes what our program
does so the cases where you want this
kind of behavior however you do not want
to give everyone access to that variable
you can declare static in a local scope
so let's get rid of this and move our I
variable back into the function scope
I'm going to stick static out the front
which means that again the first time we
run this function is going to set it
equal to 0 and create a variable in the
first place then on subsequent times is
just going to refer to that original
variable so if I run micro now you can
see I get 1 2 3 4 5 and I get the exact
same behavior as I did before however
that I variable isn't visible no global
scope it's just local to that function
now as for uses some people do like to
discourage the use of this because of
certain reasons that I don't fully
understand because I don't really see a
problem with this it definitely has its
use it's one of those things where yes
you can achieve the exact same behavior
using other methods however that can
also be said for classes you don't
necessarily have to use classes at all
to write a program however it does make
your life easier same with this case
it's one of those things that you can
just do to keep your code a little bit
cleaner
another example might be if you
singleton class so singleton class is a
class that should only have one instance
in existence if I wanted to create a
singleton class without using this
static local scope thing I would have to
create some kind of static singleton
instance probably a pointer at this rate
I'll set it here I would have to have a
if I just want to return a normal
reference I would have to have a single
some reference returning get function
which was static and returned my
instance after the referencing it of
course I would then have to actually
declare this instance over here single
term single term as instance I can
probably set it equal to the melon
pointer as a default and now I have the
ability let's get rid of this now of
course I have my singleton class in
which I could just call singleton get
and then do whatever I want with it
so suppose we had a method here called
hello don't let me know what I'm doing
just an example was call a hello method
and everything will be well you can see
we're gonna call one instance of that
class that we can use so we can kind of
use it statically now this is quite a
lot of code you don't necessarily have
to do it this way another way to do this
with our newfound knowledge of this
local static thing might be like this we
can get rid of this entirely we can get
rid of this external definition of F
instance as well and then we can just
expand our guest function to actually
create a static singleton instance and
then return that instance and there you
go we get the exact same behavior you
can see everything here stays the same
we can run our code no problem of course
the codes not actually going to do
anything at this point we can see it run
successfully without crashing and we
don't really have any problems with this
at all and you can see that our code is
a lot lot cleaner now of course if you
didn't have the static keyword here then
this singleton since it is just created
on the staff would get destroyed as soon
as you hit this curly bracket and then
the functions curve ends so this would
be a grave error especially if you're
returning it by reference if you're
copying it of course you wouldn't really
have a problem however since we are
resetting a reference to it this would
would be a huge problem however by
adding static we're extending the last
time of death to be eventually for
rather which means that every time we
call get the first time it will actually
construct that singleton instance and
then are all subsequent times it will
just return that existing instance so
this is a great example of where you
might want to use something like this it
doesn't necessarily have to be with
single terms it can help you out a lot
by replacing initialization functions
where for example you might have to call
a static initializer where for example
you might have to call it static
initialization function at some point in
your program to create all of your
objects so that you could actually use
the static get methods and stuff like
that you can just kind of simplify that
by using this in a lot of cases so you
can see there are tons of uses to this
and it's really not all that bad so feel
free to use it that's my opinion let me
know what you guys think of this static
in a local scope thing in the comments
below and I'll see you guys in the next
video goodbye
[Music]
[Music]